this is a bad idea it's a very bad idea
it's probably the one of the worst ideas
but i'ma do the bad idea
i have downloaded oh god that's awful to
look at
no shaders in minecraft i have doubt
it's still legs
god damn it
oh god this frame rate is killing my
eyes god i thought it was the shaders
that make my world lag but i just have
too much stuff going on on this bonky
you look so actually you look the same
to be fair darksven
god the water looks so blue it doesn't
it doesn't look as good damn it anyway i
got the new update to work on my new
world i'm not sure if i'm supposed to do
that especially since i'm playing on
hardcore the new warden which is new
enemy is finally in the game we can find
him that's i'm this is what i was so
excited about the new update is getting
having the new enemy warden he looks
tough man he looks really damn tough man
i'm not even sure if i can kill him
actually you guys want to see something
super satisfying
let's see how she looks like
that's kind of cool it still looks cool
it doesn't look good though
but it's got the charm i think i don't
know uh let's do a quick raid
and then that way we can get better
trading i think it's worth it like look
all this is all the mobs are spawning
but none of the are those pillagers down
there i'm not sure what's going on here
well i guess we'll see what comes up
shut up cow
no one's speaking you
oh something got sucked
oh cool
my pillager doesn't work anymore what
did it despawn or something could it be
the new update maybe it's broken i think
it's broken i mean it's working but it's
broken you know what i mean you know me
maybe it's night is it because it's
night and they don't spawn at night what
do you think kev shut up no one is
he's looking at me sleeping
weirdo you're just staring me at me all
night i would kill you if you weren't
such a pain in there to replace you
it's the only only reason you're alive
you're too annoying to replace oh it's
still got mobs happening i know why i'm
filming this it's not interesting i just
i want to know if it works i could it
could be the spawn limits of mobs hello
i am here to murder
[Music]
that's kind of ballsy shouldn't do that
oh [ __ ] you gotta be careful here
we're fine
[Music]
i'll never die
i'll have to figure out i don't know
what is happening here oh i built that i
am so confused by everything i've ever
done all right let's go back and do some
trading
all right check this out
so satisfying
i love it
yeah oh it's still coming baby
oh my god
i love it never ah a couple more baby
let me uh let me just check how rich i
am hold up one second guys
ah yes
filthy rich
dirty money
big money you see that bonky this will
all be yours
one day you're in my number one in the
wheel baby so we're gonna encounter dark
sven dark sun to punish you wanna come
with me now you have to say you died
already we're gonna encounter the most
dangerous boy in the game
we need some potions i think i already
have some
who the hell are you
don't
what a dumb name i think i want to make
so the warden has like this darkening
effect which makes it all dark and
creepy i don't want that i think i can
make what's night vision again i think
it's carrot there's a golden carrot in
it in me i gotta be honest with you guys
this could be
i know i said oh i could die
but i feel like this is really like yeah
i could definitely die
it's a nether war you extended with
which one to extend it with
oh no it's redstone really glad i have
this knowledge
do you know how to do all this adult
stuff nah but do you know you need
redstone to increase your potions in
minecraft
you didn't
converge
there you go eight minute baby should be
plenty fun all right let me kiss you one
last time bonky
cuz i'm heading off
hey buddy
i decided to give all my money to bonkey
because you're just gonna blow it all on
gambling okay
i just real no
it's the right thing and you know it all
right i need someone to take care of it
all right i'll be back minecraft god not
to give me strength
we'll head north
no it's a slower path never mind we'll
head stop
here we are baby well guess we just keep
digging baby oh god i can't use the
torch to lit up now
wait wait a minute i'm not i'm dumb not
that dumb
yeah i don't need shaders anymore i got
vision baby i don't know if night vision
works i feel like it should work yeah
it'll work
oh gosh
oh we found something
there's a couple of no no
we're going back in i need a base i need
a base that i can call home here's my
home
the thing is i watch some videos and
what i understand that's my sword and i
definitely should change my what am i
doing okay focus think
brain activate
okay that those are the things
okay
oh see it can hear me it can hear me i
don't like it i'm using this on baby
mode basically with night vision
i'm actually scared
wait focus not [ __ ] funny
you won't laugh if you die felix i just
don't trust my hole you know i need a
better indication of my whole i'm gonna
drink the potion of strain in case i
have to fight him uh which i don't wanna
so he keeps going
oh what is that different texture
i know you can find like they could lead
to a fortress as well so i think what we
should do
oh god
shut up let's not make any noise
keep going deeper in and if the warden
spawns i guess we die what's my escape
route okay i got it do i make a noise if
i'm pickaxing
they kind of sound like those super
mario [ __ ] oh god i thought something
happened the bat is like doing something
to them if you don't know what's going
on then i guess this looks super lame
but like i'm terrified
oh
no
no did he hear me did it happen
what is happening i think it happened
i'm scared
i'm going home
the darkness effect still happens even
if you have the night mission i don't
know if he spawned or not but something
did happen i think i got detected oh god
i think it spawned it must have spawned
i can't zoom okay so one thing i know is
that you can use arrows to distract him
i don't think you spawn
does that mean he spawned
what is happening
no it's so dark i think it's glitching
i'm playing like a pre
pre-release pre of a pre-release
basically i think i'm okay
we're on
wall
he spun
respawn
i'm freaking out he sees me
let's shoot an error
he took the bait
god he's terrifying
kids are gonna
minecraft is a horror game i said it
before and i'll say it again
homie i'm just chilling behind obsidian
and i'm still shooting myself
[Music]
oh god
a sound
[Music]
go away god so you can't cheese it with
a night vision
i thought i was so smart
says his heart that makes that noise
that's creepy
it's [ __ ] like cut through here
[Applause]
i think i did something
why did you sound like he's coming from
oh man
i'm innocent oh god
i feel like this could go south real
fast
oh he's on to me
i'm just gonna dig a tunnel let's screw
this
it ain't anything worth dying for i just
sound like he's right behind me i don't
like it bro he hears me he's following
me through my tunnel stop it
stop
maybe i can farm them from underneath oh
god what's happening oh god oh it's my
potion of course
oh god it's all dark now
dude it's so dark are you joking
[Music]
oh god he's right
there praying alone he doesn't have
range the thing is like i think even if
i kill him he can just respawn i want to
see how many shots it takes to kill in
three
four
[Music]
five
six
seven
hey damn
hey
okay
nine
ten i don't know if you can get
ten 11
12
13
14
15 i'm starting to think you can't kill
him
maybe he came
okay that was like 24.
i don't think he dropped anything
whoops sorry sorry sorry about that bro
don't spawn another one
[Laughter]
i want the precious new blobs did he
drop anything though i want to know oh
god it's so dark stop it i'm holding
shift harder than i ever shifted as if
i'm walking over lava and it's first
time nether with no fire resist potion
that's how hard i'm hitting ship
i don't like that sound minecraft i'm
starting to think it's not possible to
mine them from underneath
oh no maybe you can okay so i need a
nether right
[Music]
[ __ ] me he does a lot of damage
i'm done
[Music]
how many hearts were that one shot
i'm out i'm out i'm out
i got one oh i didn't even grab the
block he can fit it he's slimmer than i
thought he's away
oh god you know what i'm going to do it
i'm going to take another
portion of strength
you can have that
and brush your nitrogen because this is
too scary for me and i can't handle it
and we're gonna see if we can kill him i
don't see him i think he's in the cave
[Music]
so maybe now i can
oh they break maybe i need
uh so touch
okay still have watch
i didn't get an achievement
skulk oh me i'm scared now you saw him
you saw how much damage
i'm not even breathing dude okay that's
enough i'm out
i'm out i'm out i'm out i'm out i'm out
i'm i'm out i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm i
i'm actually out of arrows that was my
last arrow
no way anyway we're heading back
gosh
i wanna see i'm gonna i gotta watch a
replay on that hit i took
my bro oh he's so mad
i'm sorry i'm back yeah you're not gonna
be able to spend all my money my my
money look what i got a skulk striker
let's check it out
oh gosh it's night i can't even oh i
have the night mission
all right let's check it out in the
gardens
okay
whoa oh it's got like a
no
can it spawn here
if i
have i made a terrible mistake
okay
how many times do i have to tell you
nordvpn.com
slash pewdiepie
i won't say who did it but someone i
know downloaded nordvpn paid for nordvpn
without using the link there's no code
use link you want to be safe online
use a vpn you want to be free online use
a vpn you want to be epic online use the
goddamn con
anytime i travel or doing my dirty
business online you got to protect
yourself otherwise your isp will know
exactly what you're doing otherwise
other people spying on your wi-fi know
exactly what you're doing you don't want
things people knowing what you're doing
do you i know that you don't want to do
that and i won't say anything don't
worry as long as you use the goddamn
link
use the link because for every purchase
of a two-year plan which you should get
we'll get you one additional month free
baby and okay
brace squeeze your butt as hard as you
can surprise gift i see the clicks
coming in now you're all clicking on the
link i knew it they got some great deals
on nordvpn in february oh the additional
month free
is available on youtube only they are
celebrating their 10 year anniversary
happy birthday in the vpn that's awesome
new subscribers will get either one
month one year or two years on top of
discount plus one free month that's a
that's very generous you can watch
popular movies on netflix that are not
available in other countries as a strong
proponent for free and open internet i
highly recommend using a vpn trust me
you can try it out they have a money
back guarantee you will find use out of
it and if not then i will look like a
fool but yeah that's it congrats north
vpn on your 10 year anniversary thank
you for sponsoring yet another video
fantastic sponsor you guys have been
good feedback appreciate